yep
we're good
hi i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry
welcome to reasons to see.com where we
give you reasons
to see and not to see skyfall
so let's hang out
ryan's consensus there are a lot
of reasons to watch skype there are a
lot of reasons to watch
skyfall done jerry's famous consensus
there are a lot of reasons to watch
skyfall folks there are a lot of reasons
to watch skyfall
daniel craig is awesome in this film
reasons to see number one
daniel craig i mean the level of
expression and the level of just like
depth he brings to bond is awesome the
piercing blue eyes
yeah i wonder i wonder if those eyes
were cg because they're just that
piercing he's
buff yeah and his
his soul is he has such a distinctive
shape that you can always tell even if
he's in the shadows
you always know it's him there's such a
strong level of intensity he brings
behind the performance
yeah totally and i mean he's uh [ __ ]
i didn't have anything there
okay and this one too he's actually a
lot more charming he does have a
a humorous side it's like they balance
out his
toughness with a good emotional depth
and also then with the charm and stuff
it's like they're bringing a lot of the
old bond back too
he feels more like bond than ever in
this film more than more than any of the
correct ones he feels the most like bond
in this one
reason to see number two happy air bar
damn
javier bardemazin is an awesome bundle
fantastic
villain yeah and in fact he has one of
one of my favorite moments
in any bond movie i've ever seen and
also just just this year that one moment
where he's got bond tied to the chair
it's such a great moment it's such an
awesome moment such an unconventional
villain
like he he brings such a different type
of villain to a bond movie you know he's
a little flamboyant
he's a little unhinged but but he does
it so perfectly that it's
creepy and maniacal but you still get it
like you still understand he's fun to
watch but he's still threatening
he's a little bit gay reason to see
number three
the writing i love the writing of this
movie i felt that almost everyone had a
purpose in this film
bond even has a character growth it
comes full circle man
james bond had a character growth m had
a character growth
however you're part damn even you get to
explore his character it's all personal
like it's all
interrelated with mi6 and you know it's
all about
bond and m and javier bardem's character
like it's all so
tightly intertwined it's not just oh
this guy needs to take over the world we
have to stop him now yeah this is all
super personal
it's even deeper than before the movie
knew when it was supposed to be dark
it knew it was supposed to be personal
it knew when it was supposed to be fun
and adventurous
it just it was honest the script was an
honest screenplay but
it didn't feel like let's find ways
to link each big action set piece
together you don't even notice
when there's not action happening
because you're so enthralled by what's
going on with these characters and the
mystery and all that stuff
reasons to see number four q
i like q a lot in the film he was really
charming he plays off bond really well
because
they are totally different types of
characters any banter between them was
awesome i can't wait to see them play
off each other again in another film
yeah let's have a cue spin-off series
yeah just cute reason to see number five
sam mendes
bringing sam mendez on board hey he's
one of my favorite directors
revolutionary road
yeah he really seemed to know how to
combine
both this new bond that was reinvented
but it's very evident that he
loves the the other 25 000 bond movies
that were made and you had to mesh them
all together so well and create such a
perfect tone
there's bringing old bond and newborn
they're screening this this perfect
middle ground
by finding that balance between the
classic and the new there's also the
stuff about how
mi6 is antiquated and they're trying to
fight for their you know relevance
and then you've got the idea that bond
is old you know and it's a young man's
game and stuff and even you know
bond and q have that old versus new
dynamic so there's a huge you know
undertone of
old versus new i've never seen so much
symbolism before in a james bond film
sam mendez knew how to make it fun and
he knew how to make it dark he knew how
to make it personal
and he was able to make all kinds of
different action scenes i really felt
like there was an actual sense of danger
going on for james bond in this film
you know all the other bomb films joe is
like he's gonna be okay he's gonna be
fine she's gonna have sex with some
[ __ ] and he's gonna walk out of this
all right
guns blazing and this one it's weird
it's like i knew
two more sequels are on the way but i
still felt like she could go really
wrong for james bond right now
and especially after the way they opened
the film they open it on the note of
like oh he's not invincible after all
like yeah it really felt like the
directing and the writing working
together
were they were all asking themselves the
scenes that require danger
how can we heighten it and even make it
more dangerous
this one really felt like a spy move it
was great
reason to see number six cinematography
this film just looked beautiful it's
like every shot looks like a painting
and everything is so
symmetrical so well framed unlike
quantum assaults you can actually tell
what's going on in the action scene
yeah a little bit part of what's so cool
and this is a directing and
cinematography thing there's
a whole bunch of stuff in this movie
about working in the shadows and stuff
like that and
so many of the fight scenes and the
actual espionage stuff takes place in
shadows
with very minimal light or very creative
light you know there's lots of
silhouettes there's a lot of really
symbolic
cinematography here elegant but gritty
and dark i loved how they took advantage
of each location
they even captured every location
beautifully every
where they went i wanted to go there and
do what james bond was doing
i read the credits that i think they
really did shoot in all those places
yeah they shot in like every single one
of those locations and boy i'm happy
they did it
reasons to see number seven the action
there's a lot of great action in this
film
not every fight scene is the same from
the opening scene
to the fight scene in shanghai to the
fight scene in the pit
every single fight scene in it was
different in its own way
but it still kept the bomb flavor going
on throughout it you've got
the sort of gritty you know dog fighter
that we kind of brought in with the
casino royale but you've also got
the the espionage sort of in the shadow
stuff later on
fun action you got dark action you got
violent action you got all kinds of
different themes of action going on
in this film i love how each action
scene seemed necessary
at the time too it didn't seem like they
just threw in an action scene to go we
need more action like every action scene
height in the intensity of the story
yeah totally
reasons to see number eight the score
i gotta give a shout out to thomas
newman for this because i mean not just
you know the classic bond theme but like
the whole score
was really good and there was a lot of
interesting music they were doing you
know some of it was that classy
espionage music and there was some stuff
that was like
electronic but in just the right ways
the music does move
you you know it wasn't distracting when
i found myself going i really liked the
score
from the synergy from the writing
directing acting cinematography
and then topping it off with that music
wow the film just
moves you dude yeah reason to see number
nine
naomi harris naomi harris is charming in
this film
she's funny at times and that her
and james bond have great chemistry yeah
they play off each other well they do
some fun stuff with her character
reasons not to see there are only
reasons to see this movie
there aren't any yeah i mean
i guess if you're like stuffy or a [ __ ]
yeah you don't like movies or something
or if you're if you're homeless or yeah
now if you have like trauma related to
to espionage like spy related things
then maybe don't go see this movie
if you don't like charming men if james
bond had sex with you and then didn't
call you back
and like you got jumped by a bunch of
spies and pregnant
yeah oh i knew i knew a woman once
that's a spin-off
yeah i'm james bond's son what's up
we'll get y'all about to be here all
right we're done
sweetie